it's a new take on lighting the crystal
chandeliers in windfalls Munich
showrooms are bright and brightly
colored
they're designed by clarissa dawn from
Germany and who'll hoffman's from the
Netherlands they've taken this grandiose
lighting fixture and reinvented it
finally Shannon it's classic with a
twist first our there's the usual
crystal and some shapes and elements but
the way we put it all together and the
illumination has a new sense of airiness
the twist is done with small spot lights
which is how most of the chandeliers are
illuminated it's an idea that has lit up
big time the two designers sell about
1000 of these creations a year many are
made especially to order designed for
the room they'll be used in normally the
functional input outweighs the form
factor the lucidity vegan much monotone
some of the chandeliers weigh a ton so
on a course on so I'm vision when we're
installing something of that size in a
casino like the one at Leicester Square
we have to be very precise he and other
montia right down to the last millimeter
of the millimeter stem
the chandeliers are built entirely by
hand in their Munich workshop by
Sebastian hi Duke who is originally from
Poland he spends up to five or six hours
on each individual light the crystal is
sourced from the finest manufacturers
such as Swarovski working with such
precious materials is a challenge
innocent tanya's ripping these materials
here aren't cheap and when our clients
order something then what they get has
to look good in quality is important to
us windfall was launched as a company
ten years ago today they have customers
from around the world many of their most
prestigious projects are in London like
this VIP lounge at Heathrow Airport and
the restaurant at the royal albert hall
among their current projects is a palace
in jeddah saudi arabia a chandelier like
this can cost up to 800,000 heroes the
oven inlets and if we work for a very
small niche which we discovered 10 years
ago it's a design oriented niche that
appreciates beauty but the work the
quality and the attention to detail that
go into our products has its price
vanished into pies in Berlin they
created a lighting concept for a luxury
hotel suite
they're chandeliers also grace the homes
of the rich and famous exclusive clients
looking for an exclusive adornment visa
father Scott meet Avia button some of
our designs are very colorful and that's
what makes us special wheels off at all
we're rather daring in our use of color
at first people found that shocking when
they saw it but now 10 years on people
have gotten used to it talk about their
office and showroom is located in the
heart of Munich the two designers draw
inspiration from city life and their
urban surroundings even though most of
their clients come from abroad they've
also sold a few items here in Munich
like this chandelier which adorns the
showroom of a local upscale boutique
the marks and fresh plasma when you turn
on the light it's just fun when the
design we've a client's say that they
spend an hour at the dinner table
because the lights so lovely my design
far strangest
traditional crystal chandeliers are
often heavy and look and feel but in the
hands of windfalls designers they're
transformed into one-of-a-kind creations
delicate airy and contemporary